welcome to today's live broadcast PSP a
microbiology preservatives actually
supporting and enhancing the
microbiological quality of consumer
household and industrial products
presented by Johnny Brooke we are
excited to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab routes to
learn more about labyrinth please visit
www and I'll be your moderator for
today's event before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green eq a bunny located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located in the lower left
lower right finally if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the support funding at
the top right of the presentation window
or use the Q&A button to let us know
you're having a problem now I'd like to
introduce Tony Brooke Tony Brooks leads
to microbiology resource center at the
sherwin-williams company in cleveland
ohio where he is both a world-class
microbiology center of excellence to
focus on global preservation strategies
continuous improvement of industrial
hygiene practices and development of
microbiological methods to support
coating technologies application please
join me in welcoming Tony I will now
turn the presentation over to him Thank
You Rachel I appreciate that
introduction so before we begin I'd like
to disclose some cme information so I do
disclose I have the following financial
relationships I am an employee of the
Shoreham Williams company
also sit as the current chair of the
microbiology preservative subcommittee
within the consumer Specialty Products
Association i'm also a stock option
holder and advisor to lab roots so with
that I'd like to open the presentation
that we're going to speak towards the
microbiology preservative subcommittee
through the consumer Specialty Products
Association as wrath Rachel indicated
we're going to speak towards how this
committee is supporting and enhancing
the microbiological quality of consumer
household and industrial products
because she indicated i am the rmv
manager for the microbiology Resource
Center capturing Williams and as we had
already disclosed the chair of the cspa
s microbiology preservative subcommittee
so if we take a look at the agenda today
I will be speaking towards a historical
perspective on the microbial control
within consumer household and industrial
products will then speak on the mission
as well as the member participation
within the microbiology preservative
subcommittee next I will highlight some
recent accomplishments of the MPS and
then specifically speak towards a task
force that has been commissioned by the
NPS to be able to advocate towards
preservation stewardship and then
finally we will speak towards a few
future initiatives of the committee so
we look at the overview of consumer and
household and institutional product
preservation specifically looking at a
historical perspective of product
susceptibility to microbial spoilage
within the industry historically
formulations have used conventional
chemical preservatives historically the
formulations contain
high levels of solvent and low water
content and this provided some innate
capacity in and of itself to resist
microbial spoilage so the historical
formulation and conventional
preservatives protected products during
manufacturing and throughout its
lifetime of use by the consumer so
therefore microbial spoilage
historically had been of relatively low
concern for the majority of products
within this class as we moved towards
more acceptable or equal acceptable
components there's been a trend towards
increased microbial spoilage and or
susceptibility within consumer products
and if we look at the products
themselves the availability of nutrients
within the raw materials allows for
microbial contamination and persistence
to occur so the dispersants surfactants
the deformers rheology modifiers as well
as fragrances all all contribute to
nutrients the microbial contamination
can utilize to survive within these
product types the main source of
trending towards increased spoilage can
be attributed to the higher level of
water activity as the conventional
solvents have fallen out of favor these
solvents have been replaced and
reformulated with water and the water is
at a very high water activity and
available for utilization by the
organisms also many of these products
fall within the neutral to alkaline pH
range which makes it susceptible to both
bacterial and fungal contamination
really the trends towards increased
microbial susceptibility is a two-fold
trend on the left-hand side of the
screen you can see it's being driven
market trends of water-based
formulations so as these formulations
are being driven towards the use of more
renewable and biodegradable resources as
well as being driven towards trends of
removal and reducing of components that
are perceived as less sustainable so the
lack of formaldehyde releasing
technologies the removal of volatile
organic compounds the trend towards one
hundred percent a pio free materials and
the trend of low monomer content within
Paul Merrick components as well as the
water content of the materials has
really driven the trend towards
increased microbial susceptibility of
products within this industry on the
right hand of the screen you can see
that there's governmental and
non-governmental regulatory pressures
that are also driving this trend so here
is a snapshot of some of the equal
labeling as well as the governmental
organizations that are driving these
pressures from the US EPA to the
European Union's bpr and Health Canada
you can see some of the equal labeling
initiatives that are being driven by the
governmental organizations such as the
DfE the design for the environment by
the EF EPA as well as the pmra s equal
labeling initiative there's also
organizations such as lead cream seal
green Swan and blue angles that have
really driven more sustainable practices
within this industry and towards the
middle you can see the California Air
Resources Board has really driven the
impact on reduction of VO see within
product types each of these initiatives
have really increased the microbial
susceptibility of the products within
our industry so
this trend towards increased microbial
susceptible mean to the products there's
really some real consequences of
inadequate West State preservation that
impacts the consumer color issues can be
impacted so the appearance of the
products can be altered the products can
drift through pH they can impact both
the stability as well as the performance
of these products microbial metabolism
can result in off gassing and ultimately
bulging from the containers which often
can result in recalls of products off
the shelf again instability of the the
products can results from off gassing
male odor is probably one of the most
identifiable consequences of inadequate
preservation the product just smells of
spoilage and can be rejected by the
consumer but also is an indication of
microbial metabolism the results in
instability of the products additionally
viscosity drift can occur that can
require a result in both instability as
well as lack of performance of products
so as we looked at the subcommittee
looked at really the overview of
preservation within the consumer
household and institutional product
industry we really saw a need for
industry guidance around these five
facets of microbiological quality so the
first was understanding and developing
guidance for microbiological quality
assessments how do companies that make
products in this industry assess the
quality of both their raw materials and
finished products the second point
of microbiological manufacturing
controls and understanding the hygiene
requirements of a manufacturer to be
able to manufacture products that are
susceptible in a non sterile environment
the third is the microbiological risk
assessments it's really the ownership of
the finished product manufacturers
understand their formulations and their
processes can develop sound risk
assessments to understand the cept
ability of their products to microbial
spoilage and then fourth is really a key
cornerstone is understanding
preservation an understanding
preservation from really cradle to grave
through the initiation of raw materials
through the process through the
formulation and compounding the finished
product filling into your finished
product and then ultimately the shelf
life of the product itself so all those
considerations need to be understood to
truly understand effective preservation
of the finished products and then
finally staff training staff training
encompasses the microbiological quality
technicians and management as well as
the manufacturing personnel required to
be able to handle and manufacture the
products so then finally a sound
understanding of microbiological quality
is required by the formulators to be
able to formulate effective preservation
strategies within the products so with
those needs in understanding those needs
the CSP a microbiology preservative
subcommittee was commissioned in late
2008 some really initiated mission
statements and agendas throughout 2009
we've been driving industry guidance in
committing to preservation advocacy
since that point
so with that said he may be curious of
who the members of this committee are so
the committee members are
representatives of CSP a member
companies with a focus on microbiology
formulation and regulation so the
consumer Specialty Products Association
is a trade organization committed to
helping member companies drive towards
industry guidance and support for
regulation initiatives as well so many
of the companies that are part of the
cspa represent marketers formulators
contract testing labs as well as
preservatives and chemical suppliers
these are the companies that make up the
MPS as well 2shared for many of the
CFDA's cleaning products in
antimicrobial products divisions and
again we're focused on the consumer and
industrial product industry so I move on
to the next life I've laid out really
the MPS Charter and our mission
statement and the microbiology
preservative subcommittee is committed
to establishing best practices and
acceptable standards to address the
increasing concern for microbiological
quality within the consumer and
industrial products so as you've seen
the needs that we reviewed these are
those areas that the microbiology
preservative subcommittee is committing
to addressing so some of the major
challenges created by compliance the
green initiatives and the green
initiative trends are the increased
vulnerability of products to microbial
spoilage have been placed on more
emphasis of microbial quality assessment
the effective preservation as well as of
microbial manufacturing controls and
practical
risk assessments these green initiative
trends have driven constraints on the
available acceptable to robust
preservatives which have really limited
the availability and application of
chemical preservatives in the industry
today so with that the committee has
progressed towards industry guidance
we've really progressed initially with
these three standards that were issued
in 2014 I apologize it admit mystique
these are guidelines so there they are
standards they're really driven towards
trying to provide guidance to the
industry so if you look at the three
letter acronym as a prefix to each of
these guidance documents you'll notice
the acronyms stand MMG refers to a
microbiology method guidance so anytime
the committee is developing guidance of
methods will use that acronym the number
is a sequential number of the guidance
documents within iteration as this is
the first iteration of this issuance it
would be dot one and if it's ever
revised obviously that would increase
sequentially and then the year that that
hitter in says been issued would be
there so into 2014 the first ignorance
of oval one microbiology method guidance
was issued to look at the microbiology
and numeration tests really provide
guidance on how to demonstrate microbial
contamination within products and/or raw
materials within the household and
institutional products the next two
guidelines you'll see the prefixes mgg
that refers to a microbiological general
guidelines and general guidelines were
addressed and drafted
to focus on the market biology quality
of household and institutional products
as well as a draft guidance on quality
of raw materials so in each of these
three guidance have been drafted and
issued in our available online at the
consumer Specialty Products Association
website the last two guidance guidelines
have laid out really the overview
concerns and issues for microbiological
quality of both finished products and
raw material and also provide
recommended specifications for each of
those materials so I encouraged those
that are interested in learning more
about these guidance to visit cspa and
download they are available for purchase
these guidance documents are really set
at a moderate cost similar to what you
would expect to pay for an ASTM test
method so as we move into evaluating
some of the understanding of the
microbiology quality with us within this
industry in 2010 the cspa members of the
committee decided to survey the industry
with directed questions on topics of raw
material testing finished product
testing and manufacturing hygiene this
is published in 2011 in the trade
journal and really the findings
demonstrated that microbiological
quality testing is common among
household and institutional product
manufacturers however the industry
guidance wasn't really available so it
was very clear the industry guidance we
needed so even though testing maybe has
completed there wasn't always
consistency among those testing
practices
so as we move to the next slide we had
also noticed within that assessment that
there was the need for guidance for
preservation selection preservation
efficacy test methods product testing
and as well as quality expectations so
some of the considerations that the MPS
looked at the drive towards industry
guidance was providing an overview of
product preservation an understanding of
the requirements and considerations for
product preservation selection of
preservative beef on product chemistry's
so understanding which preservatives
should be selected based on the
chemistry of the products is critical
also understanding the fundamentals of
preservative efficacy methods and
providing guidance to the industry for
development of those methods and then
finally developing acceptance criteria
and guidance for the acceptance criteria
so with that regard a preservative
advocacy test method task force was
commissioned and as one of the initial
tasks of this preservative efficacy test
method task force there was a survey the
industry to more deeply understand what
was being conducted in the industry so
we the survey directed questions
pertaining to keeper ammeter zuv PT test
method and the results of that survey
were recently published this year in the
trade journal happy so the findings were
so many companies are employing
preservative efficacy test methods but
they are implementing many internal
modifications to those methods so
therefore many variations exist between
the methods however we did find that
there was a core set of similarities
between these men
with that the clear need for
standardized guidance for conducting the
PT test methods in developing those
methods machine so the preservative
efficacy test method task force has
begun the draft guidance both general
and method guidance for preservative
efficacy testing again these are
currently and draft and actively being
worked towards typically the task forces
meet on a monthly to buy monthly meeting
and then the mps meets twice per year at
a mid-year meeting in may for the cspa
meeting and then an annual meeting in
december so the first method to the
guidance is a general guideline of the
effective preservation household and
industrial products and this is really
intention is to provide an overview of
the considerations of effective
preservation it's important to
understand and remember that effective
preservation doesn't always have to
implement a chemical preservatives for
effective reservation sometimes it can
be manufacturing controls and packaging
that can have consideration towards
effective preservation the next
guidelines the method guideline is focus
on the preservatives ecstasy test method
and really the focus is not to draft a
test method per se you would consider
more algis to analogous to an ASTM
method but it's really a guideline to
detail the considerations for developing
an internal message for preservative
efficacy test methods so because of the
wide amount of variation
in modifications that we saw in the
industry this method guideline is
intended to lay out the method
development requirements I'm going to
move on to the preserve preservation
stewardship task force and this
particular task force was commissioned
to address the need of communicating
this necessity of effective preservation
strategies within consumer and
industrial products and the need was
really driven by pressure on
preservatives today the trend towards
more sustainable and natural raw
materials the restrictive use of
conventional preservatives the
continuing trend towards compliance eco
labeling for example of EPA's design for
the environment and the continuous
ongoing attack of non-governmental
organization on current preservation
strategies and last the restriction of
retailers of preservatives through
sustainability programs have put
additional pressure on the effective
preservative strategies so therefore the
preservation stewardship task force
continues to drive towards industry
guidance and in response to the trends
towards more natural preservatives a
trade journal white paper was issued to
lay out the differences between
conventional and natural preservatives
it was really initiated by concerns with
natural and non-traditional
preservatives looking at the lack of
regulatory oversight for natural and
preservatives a lack of ecological and
tox illogical testing for many of these
natural preservatives are really unknown
many of the conventional preservatives
are required through their registration
of the federal insecticide and fungicide
rodenticide act so toxic old data is
required during the registration
submission of traditional synthetic
preservatives so therefore the tax
logical evaluation and understanding is
clearly known the potential for
supplying quality issues of natural
preservatives becomes a real issue as
the natural preservatives are using
natural resources the issues that
require from seasonal development and
manufacture of these are really unknown
another microbicidal efficacy gaps with
natural preservatives are really real
many of these natural preservatives are
acid base and some of the gaps within
alkaline protection are seen so here on
the next slide I'm showing an example of
an eco labeling compliance
recommendation and this is coming from
the EPA is designed for the environment
this is driven through the from safer
chemical ingredients on the left hand of
the slide you can see the DfE has
labeled the preservatives class in four
different categories and I'm showing two
two categories here so the left side of
the screen shows the chemicals that have
been verified to be of low concern based
on both experimental and model data this
is indicated through a green oval and as
you can see many of these chemistry's
are acidic based are many of them need
much higher concentrations for use than
with in synthetic preservatives on the
right hand of the south side of the
screen is that next category and it's
the chemicals that have met the dfes
criteria for its functional ingredient
class but that has some hazard profiles
so while they recognize that this is
best in class among the safest for a
particular function the function that's
fulfilled by this chemical should be
considered for an area for safely
chemistry innovation indicated by this
yellow triangle what is of some concern
is that many of these preservatives arc
or preservatives within our industry
today so the isothiazolyl the bi t your
m CIT as well as your MIT products are
used effectively within our preservation
of products today also the
phenoxyethanol are effectively used so
as this equal labeling compliance model
had originally been initiated there was
a grandfather clause of 18 month if your
product was on any of these yellow
triangle preservatives and they would
need to be grandfathered off and moved
towards the preservatives of low
concerned so therefore the NPS developed
a working group with members of the EPA
is designed for the environment the
working group was commissioned to
address the concerns with the initial
wording of the DfE samer chemistry
initiative or innovation rather so the
yellow triangle and the grandfather
clause we really worked closely with
members from the DfE and communicated
the industry concerns regarding the
permitted state for chemical ingredients
for this preservative class we
communicated that there was weak
activity within the permitted safer
chemical ingredients we communicated
that significantly higher concentrations
may have to be required upwards of
twenty percent in the products as
compared to traditional actives and the
limited use of outline products so the
DfE within this working group provided
insight on their assessment of this
preservatives class and agree to be able
to work towards understanding and
working towards an improvement of this
people labeling so with that we worked
actively we continue to actively work
with members of the DfE DFE attend MTF
sessions katha CSP a mid-year meeting as
well as the annual meeting and offers
opportunities for members of both the
MPs and members of the DfE to be able to
work together toward this goal so within
the goal white paper was prepared at the
request of the DfE to bribe really an
overview of preservatives in the
preservative class within our products
so we prepared the white paper critical
elements of household and product
preservation in 2014 and published it
within the trade journal has provided
overview of preservatives described
classification of these preservatives
what is the activity within each of the
classifications listed the EPA label
limits as well as optimizing
preservative performance and
understanding good manufacturing
practices and the requirements today
that are all part of critical elements
to be able to ensure household product
preservation so as I move towards the
next slide this is a figure that is
taken out of that white paper and what
it shows is the current available
preservatives and the effective range of
some of the products so if you look at
the gray bars at the top you can see the
classes of fabric softeners all-purpose
cleaners laundry detergents and
dishwashing liquids so those are
arranged on the scale of the pH within
the pH scale you can see really the
traditional
age ranges for bacterial persistence
anywhere from four to nine and fungi to
be anywhere from three to ten if you
look at the dotted line you can see that
manufacturing plants exclamation of
organisms and organisms that have half
limited to those manufacturing plants
can really extend those boundaries so
it's not unheard of isolate organisms
that are able to persist as low as ph's
of two and a half and then tie as p ages
of 10 and a half we look at about the
bars below we can see the organic acids
that are within that acceptable green
oval really only available useful for
product types up to PHS of six whereas e
mi teeny mi T's are acceptable
throughout a range of pH 229 dik MIT has
a broad spectrum pH capability then OIT
has a broad spectrum range as well
they're color coded as well to show that
the organic acids have microbial
efficacy spectrum against bacteria and
fungi and the C MIT MIT are effective
against both bacteria and fungi where
MIT and bi t are only effective as a
bacterial side and OIT as a fungicide so
we look towards removing the yellow
triangle class of ingredients we can
really see the gapps zip are allowed if
only organic acids were permitted so if
we look on the left-hand side of the
screen and you see there's a dotted line
that's dividing the pH scale at ph 6 so
half in the dishwashing liquids and the
fabric softeners there are some efficacy
gaps for some bacteria for these five
types
then the real concern becomes the act
line range Africa fixing gaps both the
bacteria and fungi are seen within these
product types and there really isn't a
defective strategy for preservation so
by laying out these images in walking
the DfE through they may end understand
what those gaps meant in iterations of
their equal labeling program they were
able to remove the 18-month
grandfathering clause and now continue
to allow for the green triangle but
still understand but it's an area for
innovation even if it is the best in
class preservative for these product
types today so the next slide I'm going
to focus on the retail of driven
sustainability programs and some of the
initiatives from the preservation
stewardship and as we're beginning to
advocate for the effective preservation
within our products so these retailer
sustainable programs are really
impacting preservatives some of the
aspects of retailer sustainability
programs are listed here they are
focused on household cleaning personnel
care products some of the larger
programs have required online chemical
disclosure by January of 2015 they have
partnered with the DfE and the cspa to
be able to help with that on the online
chemical disclosure chemical reduction
and elimination of some of these
sustainability programs have prioritized
some of their top chemicals and at least
one of the same ability programs has
prioritized and these three out of the
ten of those high priority chemicals to
be preservatives so therefore you're
looking at thirty percent of those
priority chemicals to do you remove from
the product types the EPA designs for
the environment label
is again supporting some of these
programs and sustainable indexes four
ingredients are contributed so the
preservation stewardship task force
goals are really to communicate the
stakeholders that we've identified as
regulators non-governmental
organizations retailers and consumers
our position on the necessity for
responsible use of preservatives within
our industry and our products through a
holistic approach of product
preservation so again speaking towards
the cradle to grave and understanding
the development of the formulation the
manufacturing controls within the
product manufacturing the compounding
filling in shelf life and use of the
products as well are all considered to
be able to develop a holistic approach
of product preservation we've dressed
and drafted a position paper this
position paper is still currently in
draft but there's really two main points
of that of that position really the
first point is the CSP a member
companies to tend I'm preservatives for
protection of consumer industrial
products to protect from microbial
spoilage this contamination may lead to
breakdown of products and compromised
product performance as I have already
highlighted CFPA members also recognize
that preservatives handle positive
impact on the overall sustainability of
products and processes prevention of
spoilage is beneficial to the consumer
economically and results in a positive
impact on sustainability by preventing
premature disposal of consumer products
that have become spoiled
so the cspa preservatives subcommittee
is committed to drafting industry
guidance by developing mark biological
quality best practices and standards so
the manufacturer of consumer and
household products we continue to
develop and execute strategies of
preservation stewardship and advocacy so
I hope today you have given you an
overview of what is the mission and some
of the trends towards guidance that this
subcommittee has been drafting so with
that I'm going to turn it back over to
Rachel and open it up for any questions
that the audience may have Rachel free
thank you for that presentation Tony
it's time for Q&A so if you have any
questions you'd like to ask you do so
now just click on the green Q&A button
at the lower left of the presentation
window type your question into the box
that appears on your screen and click on
the send button will try to answer as
many questions as we have time for so
I'll give you guys a few minutes to
submit your question I don't see any
indicate now I guess Joey do you have
any final words before we wrap up this
presentation yeah Rachel you know if I
you know look back at really the mission
of the microbiology preserve the
subcommittee I really am trying to bring
awareness of what is the goals that this
committee is interested in driving
guidance and the best practices of
consumer and household industrial
standards so it's really a two-fold
mission of driving guidance as well as a
sound commitment to advocating
preservation stewardship for our
products really see it as a increased
need to be able to communicate as
there's a lot of voices on the opposing
side for putting pressures on our
current preservation strategies and
there's very little preservatives that
Oh around to be able to replace the
current strategies so therefore we see
it as a major initiative via blueprint
awareness to the initiatives of this
task force great thank you once again
Tony I would also like to thank our
sponsor labyrinth for making today's
educational web tracks possible before
we go I wanna let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through februari 2016
you will receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live events
that's all for now thank you for joining
us we hope to see you again soon